et autres [ __ ] un seul un lycée de
rennes caen
qui coule et faire 700 sont bas
bah on va se marier cannes et moi c'est
ce trait nouvelles hein c'est pas un peu
plus durs a annoncé c'est pas ça mais
c'est quoi alors yann à 63 ans il a 63
ans
oui ouais non mais [ __ ] mélanie temps
fiancée à 18 ans depuis ce que ton frère
tu dis ce que tu vas mieux qu'il va
bientôt pouvoir rentrer à la maison les
rageux engagés notamment pour les
ménages
tu couches avec elle je ne couche pas
avec elle même si je progresse bien
c'est un brave garçon respect
qu'est ce tu fais là c'est maman qui
attend des mesures on s'inquiète c'est
tout depuis on en a plein nouvelle
j'ai très bien
et avec ton mari tout va bien
[Musique]
pour 15 jours
s'il ne porte pas plainte on ne peut
rien faire moi je porte plainte
c'est cette fois s'apprête à graver les
choses
[Musique]
je veux juste pas lui faire du mal
mais
[Musique]